heroisch wehrfähig soldatisch so
inszenierte sich die Bundeswehr zuletzt
doch es gibt nicht nur Beifall
dass wir keine müssen Mission Impossible
Filmchen drehen darüber was bei der
Bundeswehr alles passieren könnte wie
bei in Hollywood in der personalwerbung
muss die Bundeswehr vielleicht auch ein
bisschen realistischer sein das Problem
die Abbrecherquote ist zu hoch und
schlimmer es fehlt dann Nachwuchs die
Truppe will gegen Steuern gelingt das
nicht hat das schwere Folgen auch für
die zeitenwände
und das bedeutet die Welt danach
ist nicht mehr dieselbe wie die Welt
davor Dienstag Mittag in einer Kasernen
Baden-Württemberg antreten zu
Minenräumung es gibt letzte Instruktion
denn wenn Sie hier wirklich nach
Kampfmittel nach Linien suchen dann sind
Sie wirklich in einer besonderen
Gefährdung vorsichtig tastet man sich
heran was hier bei der Übung explodiert
sind zum Glück nur Luftballons in einem
echten Einsatz hätte es jetzt schwer
Verletzte geben können Alexa und den
anderen 11 Teilnehmern gefällts zwar
sind sie keine echten Soldaten könnten
es sich aber mal vorstellen sie alle
machen ein fünftägiges Praktikum alle
wissen dass ein Job bei der Truppe auch
Gefahren mit sich bringen kann
abschrecken tut sie das nicht
entscheidet sich man kann ins
Kriegsgebiet geschickt werden und man
kann auch im Krieg sterben und das ist
ja dann meine Entscheidung und ich denke
mal jeder der bei der Bundeswehr ist der
hat sich dafür entschieden und er möchte
da machen weil er halt für sein Land
kämpfen möchte die Bundeswehr ist
dringend auf Leute wie Alexa angewiesen
vor allem wenn sie sich später
entscheiden würde sich längerfristig zu
verpflichten denn der Trend zeigt nach
unten zählte die Bundeswehr 1990 noch
knapp 1960.000 Soldaten sank die Zahl
danach rapide auch durch die Aussetzung
der Wehrpflicht momentan zählt die
Truppe knapp 181.000 aktiven zu wenig
das Ziel liegt eigentlich bei 203.000
Soldaten bis 2031 klappt das nicht hat
das Folgen Deutschland hat der NATO
bestimmte Dinge zugesagt gerade für die
Ostflanke für das Baltikum zum Beispiel
eine komplette Division ab 2025 und wenn
das nicht funktioniert dann klappt
vielleicht die eine Division die zweite
die für einige Jahre später ebenfalls
zugesagt ist die wird dann schon viel
schwieriger
attraktivitätsproblem trifft zeitenwände
es braucht einen Kraftakt das weiß auch
Boris Pistorius und legt in dieser Woche
erstmal seine stimmvisite in einem
karrierecenter der Bundeswehr ein die
Probleme die Bewerber abschrecken sind
eigentlich alte Bekannte eine marode
Ausstattung oder wechselnde dienstorte
keine guten Voraussetzungen mit der
freien Wirtschaft um immer weniger
Schulabgänger die Zeit drängt der
Minister fordert mehr Kontaktpflege und
mehr Tempo mir ist wichtig dass wir die
Zeitspanne kurz halten zwischen einer
Anfrage bei der Bundeswehr dem ersten
Beratungsgespräch dem ersten assessment
und einer Einstellung diese Zeiträume
müssen kurz sein dazwischen muss betreut
werden dazwischen muss klargemacht
werden wir haben dich nicht nur einmal
angeguckt wir wollen dich auch auch in
niederstätten legen sie sich ins Zeug
die Projektwochen soll es im nächsten
Jahr noch öfter geben sie sind ein
Baustein mit dem die Bundeswehr sich
öffnet und attraktiver werden will so
bekommen die praktikumssoldaten auch
noch einen Rettungshubschrauber gezeigt
es sind persönliche Erfahrung aus erster
Hand alexander ist begeistert der
16-jähriges Fan von der Fliegerei ein
anderer Job kommt für ihn derzeit nicht
in Frage
dass ich irgendwann mal Teil hier von
sein kann dass ich
helfen kann später im wenn es wenn er
Ernstfall kommt helfen kann man dann zu
verteidigen
das Person von der Bundeswehr so
überzeugt sind ist nicht die Regel im
Gegenteil die Bewerber Zahlen geben
zurück zwischen Januar und Mai waren es
im Vergleich zu vorher rund 7% weniger
also das junge Männer und Frauen damit
rechnen mussten über Monate irgendwo in
Auslandseinsätzen zu sein getrennt von
der Familie und inzwischen ist ja die
Lage auch so dass ich viele überlegen
ist das dann vielleicht eine
Kriegssituation für die ich mich jetzt
verpflichte was tun wäre nicht einfach
die Wiedereinführung der Wehrpflicht ein
Gegenmittel fraglich sie ist politisch
umstritten zudem fehlt es schlichtweg an
Kreiswehrersatzämtern Kasern und
Ausbildern wenn wir jetzt hunderte neue
Kasernen bauen dann investieren wir in
Beton und nicht in Köpfe außerdem würde
eine Wehrpflicht eine hightech-armee wie
der Bundeswehr überhaupt nicht nutzen
weil wir natürlich Dienstzeiten brauchen
von etwa zwei Jahren bis die jungen
Leute ihre Systeme Waffensysteme und
einsatzsysteme beherrschen was wenn die
Personalnot anhält einige auch die
werbeauftragte denken bereits über eine
Reduzierung von Stärke und Fähigkeiten
nach man kann nicht mit immer weniger
Soldatin und Soldaten immer mehr
Aufträge übernehmen das ist nicht mehr
zu leisten das heißt es braucht eine
schonungslose sehr kritische
Bestandsaufnahme der übernommenen
Aufgaben immerhin auf viele der
Teilnehmer hier scheint die Bundeswehr
später einmal zählen zu können die
Schnupperwoche zeigte Wirkung auch Alexa
will zu Truppe wenn auch erstmal nur für
ein Jahr zum freiwilligen Wehrdienst
also ich möchte schon zu Bundeswehr aber
man geht da schon mit vielleicht ein
bisschen gemischten Gefühlen hin dass ja
keine leichte Entscheidung für mich
persönlich kommt gerade eher dieser
freiwillige Wehrdienst in Betracht für
12 Monate einfach mal reingucken das ist
nur ein Jahr und wenn ich danach sag nö
ist nichts für mich dann kann ich ja
immer noch gehen und was anderes machen
die Bundeswehr muss sich also weiter ins
Zeug legen es braucht nicht nur
Milliarden für modernes Gerät sondern
vor allem Soldaten und Spezialisten die
das bedienen können denn am Ende geht es
auch um die Frage ob die zeitenwände
gelingen kann